- But, you know, the thing about Idol is,
it's just a fun gig.
I mean, when you,
when you are part of
being the first people
to see a star being born,
I mean, when you look at like, I mean,
I was riding down the road,
listenin' to the radio
and I'm listening to
Gabby Barrett's second single.
And obviously we know that,
you know, her first, you know,
her first single was just
massive and now I'm like, God,
I never will forget her
walking in the room.
And I knew that she was
just a world-class singer.
And, obviously working with
Lionel and Katie and Ryan,
it's no drama, you know, I'm not,
I'm not trying to be a bigger
star than Katy Perry and Lord,
we know we'll never be a
bigger star than Lionel Richie.
So everybody has their fun little role.
And we just focus on the kids.
We don't, we're not in it for, you know,
we're not in it to go, you know.
- That's the coolest part,
to be surrounded by people.
I love that too.
Like, when you're, I've,
I've worked with actually
Legend, John Legend
on a couple different shows,
like, you know a singing competition show.
And, one thing I love
that we've kind of had
sitting in on the previous show
and now on The Voice, like,
is we both just love music.
We're like that too.
We really feed off of
each other a lot too.
And then obviously Blake and,
and Gwen's on this season.
So it's like, once you
have people, you know,
you and Katie and Lionel,
y'all are already established,
you've already done so many things.
You're already excited and you
make it about these artists,
you know and less of yourself.
That's I think that's
when you win inevitably.
And that's, that's really cool.